so we're talking about shoes we're
talking about jay-z joining Puma and
he's gonna be their creative director
you got two of the top players of Marvin
Bagley DeAndre Aiden they're going to be
wearing Puma they've signed on with Puma
so all of a sudden the door opens Kevin
Costner walks in and I look down I go
you got Pumas on ya now what are the
odds of us talking about Puma and you
got now
you didn't just buy those did you know I
about a week ago I said my wife gave me
these Pumas and there was a leather on
leather I said no I want the shiny white
and the thing that's what I had when I
was I had him at one point in my life
and you know she she didn't this showed
up so a little icebreaker for you and I
know I like that put your can you put
your shoe up there on the yeah yeah here
we go look at that we're gonna get you a
Pullman deal maybe JC's watching he'll
sign to you I identified them early in
the history of that
what's your first tennis shoe you
remember it was that one well I mean I
remember getting per cells in Converse
but though the first one was I think I
was telling you it was the first time I
own two of anything and it was for
basketball and it was a big deal and you
could almost tell your economic position
in life you know and in public school
it's like guys who had a second pair in
their locker he's like he comes from
money you have money is exactly right
and it was Pumas and you know they make
you feel fast
what's that to slogan no it was felt I
just well you know even my I get to to
my boys are in lacrosse and when I get
them cleats it's weird they do exactly
what I did when I was eight or nine they
just run up the halls they're just
certain about the traction they just
they just run in the house they run in
the house you just feel fast okay you
played a lot of sports obviously you
played these characters in movies but
how were you in high school like what
kind of athlete I was at I was an
average athlete I understood all the
games I played you know basketball ball
baseball and football but I went to like
four different schools nine ten eleven
twelve and every place I went to I was
trying to figure out what spot I could
get into so I was a I kind of developed
a lot later I got my strength and it
might my senior year and into college
how big were you when you graduated high
school I was about six foot when I
graduated high school and I went about I
think that's six one so but as a
sophomore I was five - and you know that
because you got your license you know
everybody wants to see it you know and
about the third time a girl goes five -
I was thinking I guess I am you know
that cute thing I'd never showed it
again five to five to less than a
hundred when did you when did you know
though that you could actually like you
you had talent for being an athlete like
that you could have played you played
college I you know I remember I remember
when we were making Valderrama because
sports us something you don't project I
could have been I could have been
because anybody that's played I never
played Division one anything I wasn't
the best player on in my high school but
you know sports is a funny thing where
you can tell you can get better and the
guys who want to get better they do and
you know so some guys make it as a pro
then they weren't and I had a feeling
that I could play farther but it would
it didn't really didn't show up in high
school showed up more in college as I
was just playing a lot of intramurals
and I remember I'd never hit a home run
in organized baseball pitched a lot of
game never hit a home run but when we
were working out for Bull Durham I'm now
I'm bike at 27 and we we interview so
many athletes because we made up for
teams and basically the first day
everybody's hitting everybody said and I
know I'm gonna have to hit and I really
didn't want to be watched I just didn't
really want to be watched I didn't when
I was doing everything that I could just
stay away and those minor league parks
are big so I didn't want to lose balls
so I finally got up there I realized
everybody managed all 60 of them to turn
around and watch because here was I'm
thinking whoa the first pitch I tipped
at it dropped straight down a plate just
like Field of Dreams that's why I put
that moment and fill the dreams we're
gonna hit it out there and just drop
down like a limp yeah
but I backed out of the box because I
thought you know I I didn't like whiff
but so once I guess I then I hit this
this line drive to short sup that
wouldn't have bent the grass it was
sometimes you get a dead ball and it
went yeah but I was thinking okay okay
and a third pitch went about 370 went
out and I'd never hit a homerun in my
life and I started to think you know
sometimes we think we're done it if
you're not drafted at 18 if you're not
you know on these things and I can't
project what it would have been but I
managed to play most of the with most of
the pros and a lot of the college
programs around the country well we we
develop at a different age you know
they're guys who in high school that
they were as good as they're ever gonna
be when they're in high school yeah and
then all of a sudden you get to be 24
and you're 25 you go you know I'm
actually I'm not in here yeah but it's
too late and those same guys you know
when they get into college you know you
know it's the first time some of them
sat on the bench I I just lost my friend
Augie Garrido of you Tia three three of
my friends are Division one baseball
coaches and you know used to talk about
the guys that were on the bench and he
said look at theirs
you can either there's two ways to watch
a game you know you're they're gonna
pout and make sure everybody in the the
coach sees you or you know because that
is the first time for a lot of them but
he used to say you know look at there's
two ways you know to watch the game you
can either watch the game or you can
actually watch a game and see what's
trying to happen and he was there's a
lot of ways to coach players but when it
when it becomes their time they they
that makes a difference to them you also
by the way full introduction here you
you're up there in the four slash guy so
it's actors / producer / director /
musician / yeah what's your favorite / I
tell you I I really like directing and I
and I and I and I love the hours of rock
and roll you getting you're not up early
on anything in that game I do like being
on stage to perform because it's one of
the few times when it doesn't get
stopped with a selfie or anything
there's two hours and that's why I
started this band 14 years ago and we
played I only did it to play wherever I
was
making a movie that was it because
usually I was some target in a radio
station and then a grocery store or
something and and it's a perfect it was
almost a perfect metaphor for when I do
things right there's no plan and when I
and and you do it because you want to do
it and what's your first concert well
I'm well the first one I got paid for
was a that's the point where that's
where I was headed is I I didn't intend
to do it and now that we're done 14
years later I played the Grand Ole Opry
three times played the Kremlin you know
played South America but we've really
and we play our own music our own our
own compositions what was the first
concert you went to as a fan I the first
one I went to was the Beach Boys Chicago
at Anaheim Stadium and you knew the
songs and it was just one of those
perfect perfect days but that was the
first one I went to but didn't you you
worked at Disney Land in you know I
didn't like my first wife was know why
oh I thought you worked on like a cruise
now that I've seen that I've seen that
story but that wasn't wasn't me I tell
you what I did though when I was about 5
years old my we were living in Compton
and we didn't have a lot of money and
one guy said you know Mike that's when
Disneyland wasn't doing so good
we just started they were they're gonna
fill it some guy came to my dad and said
hey Bill you want to take your boys to
Disneyland and my dad was you know
McDonnell Douglas was having a big night
there look and he goes yeah yeah yeah he
didn't work for them and we went there
and as soon as we got there my brother
took off with my dad and my mom went
with me and I went right to where I
wanted to go which was those that Grand
Canyon thing that's one they had just
the Mules real mules and I rode that
thing wrote it like four times right and
and my mom had to do it to the fifth
time I was going back she goes Kevin and
there was like yellow tape up and I said
come on mom we can make this and she
said no there's some people come with
her I said if we hurry we could make it
and she goes Kevin and I ran into that
thing and I hit this one guy and I
buckled them my mom was like everything
got real quiet and everybody stopped and
I looked up there's this guy and he and
he looked down me because you like this
ride and I said I love this ride and the
guy goes what
think your mom's over there so I said I
thought heck we shouldn't be going again
but okay so I went underneath awhile I
went back a little tape and I went back
to my mom and she looked at me and these
men walked by and she goes do you know
who that was I said no she cuz that was
Walt Disney oh yeah I just buckle them
but I always I always thought to my
always thought I always thought to
myself that when a guy like that built
the things he did there were so many
doubters so many doubters and the level
of detail he went through for all of us
to be honest you know and then I think
when I walked away I'll bet money that
guy he turned around and looked at those
other dudes and said that's why we do
yeah we do
yeah because that kid he doesn't like
the ride he loves the ride all right
let's go you know I mean I because that
he knows you know he could live through
other people Kevin Costner plays the
gruff dangerously influential owner john
dutton in of yellowstone ranch
are you are you gruff dangerously
influential well I
he's a fifth-generation rancher who acts
like a CEO on and what we're describing
is the largest single ranch in the
United States and he has unfortunately
had to move into that area of politics
whereas the generations before him it
was just the land so you know we so
where we pick up this story there's a
lot of urbanization trying to break up
my stuff a lot of golf courses trying to
come in the EPA say and you can't move
rivers you know there's a lot and then
we have Native American issues and they
run right through the heart of this this
show Yellowstone and we shoot it right
in the Bitterroot Valley and if you
don't know where that is it's in Montana
but more significantly it's where Lewis
and Clark went right through so part of
the charm of the movie is the land
well Yellowstone premieres tomorrow
night and that'll be at 9:00 on
paramount Network yeah correct now did
you take a canoe trip
did you follow Lewis and Clark yes I
went down some of the rivers that they
went down I built like three canoes I
was a pretty impression well kid you
know I when I saw when I see something I
like I just try to emulate it but that
life of
westward expansion of being somewhere
and just living by your wits for
whatever reason really appealed to me I
mean I I used to nice to kill animals
rapid [ __ ] and skin him and take him to
school and I'd have to come home with
notes he can't keep coming here with his
stuff he didn't it didn't fly in Compton
it didn't fly anywhere wait you killed
animals and took him to school without
know the skins Oh would I would tack
them up because I liked when I saw what
the Native Americans had done is like
yeah their skin they tacked them up in
the way they look straight
everything about stuff I would try to
copy you must have been great he's
show-and-tell I was you know I told a
really weird I've never told this story
but it's interesting you ask that I I
remember I in kindergarten was
show-and-tell and I brought my dad's
3030 and I and I've just walked it down
the street oh my I walked it you know I
walked it right in and you know we're
supposed to be the coolest stuff you had
that was a school of stuff we had were
you big enough to carry us there was
really really heavy and in Yellowstone I
use it in Yellowstone for my dad it's in
the show as a tribute to him this yeah
yeah well uh you know back time where I
had to I went home a lot with notes like
he's did they have parent teacher
conferences back then I'm curious what
your they did well it the only thing I
knew about the parent conference was
when they were had and then when they
come home that night because they it's
in the dark they go and I remember and
when they came in I would really listen
to see how this was gonna go for me and
if if my dad would come in a little
hallway and if we went to the right he
was just gonna have a talk with me if he
went to the left he was getting the belt
and I knew it I just knew it and you
know and I didn't put everything
together just like to know if it's this
parent-teacher conference thing was not
good for me you know you know it wasn't
good for me it's like you did what and
my problem was I couldn't remember what
I had done that could bring on such you
know
the pain yeah but I'm I remember my dad
would get a in belt and I had two older
brothers so I would always he would say
who wants to go first and I would go
last because he'd be tired out so my
older brother Mike would he would he
would take it he'd take the hit and then
my brother Bill and then I'd be there
and I had to act like it hurt yeah
because I didn't want my dad to think
that he was letting up you know or my
brother you have such a good survival
instinct I mean when my dad would make
that left I'd already start crying and
I'd hear him you're not you're not hurt
yet and just to hear those footsteps or
they open up a door and then you're
likely yeah you can hear it coming off
the hook you know that sounds like you
could use that as a scene have you ever
had a scene where I've you know I gotta
tell you I had one of those kind of
Huckleberry Finn Eliza's you know it and
I have used so much of it but and I just
I just had so many experiences that I
have been able to you know you know put
forth and as a result of it I also you
take pride in you didn't you never had
sequels well I don't sit pride I just
not know it's not and I would do one I
wanted to do one for Brooks mr. Brooks I
wanted to do and but they oh they always
have to get over the writing has to get
over the bar and and so what happens is
when people want to do a sequel they
just want it to go as quick as you can
and the one you made took a long time
it'd be hard you know you know Ron and I
are flirting with doing another movie
together called you know q-school Ron
Sheldon yeah and but it's been a long
time for us and and that stuff but you
know the sequel world is just go as
quick as you can get you into the
theater as quick as you can shake upside
down and if that movie's no good you
make the third one as a Nepal as I know
you'd have to apologize for that when it
get to make the third one so it's a
business and I and I honor it I get
but it hasn't fit into me and and
actually it's not not prideful about it
or at all it was good business to do
that so I frustrated a level of because
it wanted the bodyguard to and wanted
the open range and the tin cup and the
bull drums and this so we talked about
that a year ago which we did frustrated
and and and I I mean there is something
that's there it's just it's like when
people say you know would you ever go
back to do SportsCenter
well I wouldn't because I can't be as
good as I was I'm never I just I can't
capture that and I don't know if you
feel that way like if I do Bull Durham
or I do Field of Dreams
like what's my role in or yeah well you
see it on paper
listen some of those movies on paper
that they want you to do a second one if
no one wanted to do the first one Ron
and I run and I walked around like a
couple of hookers on Santa Monica trying
to get somebody to look at this script
we we went through all the studios twice
and finally we got down to Fox at one
point and they would do it for four
million and we said look we can't we
can't do it for 4 million and I went to
Orion and I had just done no way out for
them and I said they had to move
baseball movie that's why I didn't go to
him they had eight men out and they had
it Rodney Dangerfield comedy the Scout
or something like that so I would have
been pressing my friendship with him to
say would you take a third baseball
movie but after everybody said no I was
up for everybody's all-american and the
script started to change a little bit I
like what Deford written I didn't want
it to change at all and it's began to
morph a little bit and I decided to hang
with Ron and I finally went back to
Orion I said look you got till noon
tomorrow
to tell me what you're gonna do and in
at noon they looked at it and they said
we'll make it and for six million we
made Bull Durham and what's that car
worth what's your Mustang is that you're
Shelby yeah there's no I don't know what
it's worth now but it's in the garage
it's in the garage
yeah it's a it's never let go of it no
the boys do it what's out there the kids
get to drive it
yeah it's but it's like a go-kart so
it's it almost never makes a trip home
it goes out and then
and then then then automobile come comes
and then I'm on the side of the road and
people wanting autographs it's it
doesn't work for me anymore all right
these guys complained that they wanted
to ask a question but they complained
how they did because can we ask a
question now how about collectively we
come up with one good question for Kevin
okay yeah so time want just one and
that's it gannets are getting together
the cooking set yeah sometimes yeah what
people come in yeah but the other man
cave that's up in Connecticut that has
all the toys the gold simulator and the
basketball hoop that kind of stuff I
know yeah something and it was dangerous
back then they didn't want us doing what
we were doing like you're trying to
fight to have Durham produced and then
you know so that's part of it that made
it great is your fighting hard for it
instead of somebody saying we're gonna
drink come on in here's your secret here
all right you got your one question for
Kevin Costner seaton since yours you
have a foot in each is it tougher to act
like an athlete or tougher to act like a
musician and which do you sort of judge
more harshly when you're watching well a
lot of people think you know Olivia
maybe it was our greatest actor and
there's one role he couldn't pull off
and that's baseball or football you know
immediately you cannot out act it you
it's it's it's just you just you look
and it's in it's in if if you've so many
coached in your life please don't be
dismissive of somebody you go okay I'm
gonna try to have more thing but in
sports is just gonna know right away you
know you just go no you know and and and
it's and I what I think is interesting
about sports meter is even the non
athlete knows that you know and and and
the great thing and singing you know is
that you don't have to be a great singer
to know great one you can just tell you
know and there's music I remember I had
to talk with John Berry when he's making
a score of Dances with Wolves I didn't
know where he was at in his career at
that
that point I was very could be a very
volatile guy and he would he'd been out
of the business for a couple years for
whatever reason so I'm like this like a
mongoose playing with a cobra right so
he brings me the five it was like all
the money in the world and and I didn't
have very much and and he was gonna
write some music and he goes I'd like to
have a piano up in my room like in a
hotel room he goes yes and he go and I
said I said well can I listen to no I
don't play in front of anyone
oh my go okay so so he did and and and
and then we when he brought he actually
had a cassette tape of like six six
pieces that he thought he could craft
into the movie and and I was with my
friend Jim Wilson and and we were still
thinking about the bill in the hotel and
he comes in and I liked about four of
them and there was two of them I just
didn't see how were they were gonna fit
and I didn't realize he was a guy that
was like unedited on anything and I just
said you know and this these other two
and he's like look at man there must be
some smoke coming out of it but he just
kept looking at me come mm-hm and you
know the reality though is he could make
the music but really as a novice or
whatever you will I had to judge it
because it's it's it's you know you
don't have to take a step back from
understanding what's good you may not be
able to do it and sports us that way we
know who can play we see who can play
and and and it's the same way with music
it's great to see you
and glad you stopped in hope you enjoyed
you know I know that we sometimes touch
on the same topics but you know we're
fascinated with those topics but no we
make a good circle I like you know I
like I'm and you know and you know one
thing I like about coming it was there's
no pre-interview we just let it fly and
I started off on my puma you know and
I'm thinking it's just better to shoot
like that it's just so much easier it
actually makes the room more authentic
and you've always uh you guys have we
can I can't believe you should kind of
cut you guys that's one question yeah we
we take great pride in not
preparing yeah yeah yeah yeah well I
tell you what if you know it's a if it's
a continual recess
that's what I was looking for out of
school sometimes I bring the belt out
though Kevin you're not hurt yet Kevin
Costner in he's John Dutton of
Yellowstone Ranch Yellowstone premieres
tomorrow night June 20th at 9:00 on
paramount Network and it turned out
better than I thought so if you get a
chance see it it turned it really turned
out good and it and it's a lot of fun
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]